we're here with best buds casey wilson
and daniel schneider
and we have just had the best time you
can look at the floor it pretty much
shows how we're rolling around here um
this story was really interesting to me
would you ever wonder what would happen
if the bachelorette and bridgerton had a
baby well pop sugar reports that that's
just what you'll get in the newest
dating show on nbc called the courtship
a young single woman named nicole remy
will live in an old regency era castle
with a group of suitors who will try to
woo her with carriage rides archery and
handwritten love notes nicole's real
life parents will be there too to make
sure the gentleman's intentions are good
casey danielle please give us your
thoughts now i'm a huge bridgerton fan
but um i will say like these were like
dukes and real dukes and duchesses we
were dealing with and i don't know this
is just going to be some like accountant
from paramus no offense but i kind of
feel like you know when you go home he's
still that yeah so he's going to be like
a dental hygienist from rhode island
which is all fine but it's not quite the
like dressed up look we're expecting i
think at the end of the day i want him
in jodhpurs all the time yes right you
don't want the fantasy to end no no no
and yeah when you get home and you're on
tick tock and he's on fantasy football
it's not a remember when it used to be
candlelight well that's because you
didn't have electricity dear that's why
it was romantic
what's next okay so next up we have the
new york times reports that this is the
year of weddings
favorite movie in the world thank you so
much i did write it with my friend june
daniel rayfield anyway it's going to be
completely bananas uh but the end of 20
by the end of 2022 there will be over
2.5 million weddings which is the most
since 1984. so the competition for
venues and vendors is making it so
expensive and difficult to plan but it's
also expensive for guests in 2019 guests
spent an average of 430 dollars to
attend a single wedding and this year
the numbers are going up
it's true i mean i can i just say it's
just i'm terrified i have two weddings i
have to sell my house i can't cook
i never really get invited to weddings i
don't know why well
i mean i feel like i'm a good guest i'm
a good time gal when
when i have a second wedding if my
marriage crumbles you are my first
invite
and i will get married just to have you
thank you
so much
actually i do have a wedding i'm going
to this year i was just going to say i i
do think you have been invited to one
wedding this year i'm actually your
flower girl that's right miss barrymore
the first one
so this year is looking up for me but as
the like birther of bride wars what do
you think about the fact that and it's
interesting because they said not since
1984 which makes me do the math in my
mind and think the reason the wedding
industry actually changed and there's
all this data on it is because of
princess diana's wedding
and that fairy tale wedding like
changed the wedding industry and here we
are all this time later having a banner
year what do you think i mean i think
you're right it was the people's
princess that changed us all on a
cellular level when i saw her with that
long
80 foot train
train yes and i think also kovid
obviously people are just trying to
scramble to get those venues yeah
because we couldn't we had to push
things on pause for like two years and
now you know it feels like now's the
time honey do it i guess what i'm really
getting at is bride wars 2022 yeah
[Music]
right there a possibility
of another movie a prequel a sequel
and i'm on it i know someone who can
star
hello hello and the other star
we'll fight it we'll sort of see how it
goes i mean look we'll cast her first
and then see what happens next yeah
we'll go from there when you say you're
on it are you i mean are you really
going to do it is it could there be a
reboot i'm going to make it happen you
know i'm going to i'm going to go
actually instead of
perfect on that
[Music]
you